Michelle Williams reveals she was
suicidal at the height of her Destiny's
Child Fame I apply depression doesn't
mean lazy self-harm don't mean you want
attention it's it's you know it's not
any of that
after Demi Lovato got candid about her
battle with depression in her new
documentary simply complicated I'm on a
journey to discover what it's like to be
free of all demons the ladies of the
talk had a roundtable discussion on
Wednesday where Michelle spoke out about
her own mental health struggles I think
at the age of 25 and I had an aim to
what I was feeling at the time I
wouldn't disclose that I've been
suffering from depression you know I
didn't know until I was in my 30s what
was going on I just thought it was
growing pains I just thought I'm turning
into a woman so I've been suffering
since the age of between 13 and 15 I
just did like I said at that age I
didn't know what to call it so I applaud
her for coming out and sharing her story
because so many people are walking
around the DC alum and guest co-host
also shared how she wants to get rid of
the negative stigma surrounding mental
health when I disclosed it to our
manager at the time bless his heart he
was like y'all just signed a
multi-million dollar deal you're about
to go on tour what do you have to be
depressed about his Matthew knows yeah
Matthew knows and Beyonce's dad yeah
yeah yes so I went to him you know but
it's kind of like he could have been
right you know at the time I should I
should be I think he wanted me to be
grateful which I was but I was still sad
you know and so I just I want to
normalize this mental health discussion
how did you treat it and like how how
bad did it get and then how did you come
out the other side um so I got really
really bad I'm never I've disclosed my
depression in the year 2013
not on purpose just you know just
disclosed it
to the point of I was suicidal I was I
was to that place where that's so dark
and heavy and people think I think like
Matthew Knowles but oh if you have X Y &
Z you should feel good inside and that's
just not how I work I think he was
trying to like no you're good you're
okay yeah I think people who who are
fortunate enough to not suffer from
depression or anything like that simply
can't understand it I want to normalize